así después este vacuno dromo o mega
centro de vacunación viene a completar
la tarea que ya están haciendo los 25
puestos de vacunación que haya que ya
están en funcionamiento en todo el
departamento desde hace 11 semanas más o
menos que comenzó la campaña de
vacunación en el país la idea acá como
le decía son esas 10.000 dosis y hay que
saber que de esas 10 mil 5.000 son
solamente para los habitantes de este
departamento aquí donde la tasa de
incidencia está por encima de los 700
casos por 100.000 habitantes cuando en
el país en promedio está sobre los 370
400 casos por 100.000 habitantes y la
idea también es que a través de la
plataforma telefónica las personas
únicamente aquellas que viven aquí en
este departamento puedan agendar su cita
así que se le ha dado una prioridad a
los habitantes de este departamento que
es uno de los que son más densamente
poblados del país